oh all right i'm [ __ ] bored talking
about anime
anime we're not even an anime podcast
anymore imagine talking about anime on
trash face guys
i i feel like i i'm i'm attempting to be
the winnie the pooh meme
like the the the like high class when i
talk about anime i'm trying to form
opinions i don't have opinions story
i don't have welfare watch that [ __ ] i
don't have well-formed opinions about
things
i just say what i feel okay i mean you
don't have well-formed opinions about it
so like like anime food
gaming like let's be honest here let's
be honest here i went on a little rant
on my stream the other day just being
like gone is actually like your parents
didn't beat you enough
because like because right
listen he was allowed to get away with
not eating crusts
right if i didn't eat my crust oh i
think i saw you talking about
if i didn't eat my crusts right you know
what my parents would do they'd be like
that's fine connor you have dinner ready
for tomorrow now
yeah and i'll be like but mom i don't i
don't want them she's like no connie you
can [ __ ] cross you're not wasting
food who says that i didn't get my ass
beat for not eating my crust
did you did you get will you learn a
little bit of this
mother i will not bow because because i
had gone my entire [ __ ] childhood
having to like being forced to eat my
crust so as soon as i was a fully grown
adult
who could make my own [ __ ] decisions
i'm gonna be i was i was
i was like mother i do not care what you
think anymore
i'm going to not eat my crust i hate my
own rice
i pay my own bills i buy my own food
[ __ ] you
mother sorry all i'm saying is you
should've got the backhand a little bit
more you know whatever yeah
that's such a bad joke i'm so sorry
there is there is something that
like i didn't fully appreciate as a kid
or like
i didn't fully cross like i'm not
crushed good food not cross but like
we're not going to get a food by the way
we're not getting into food again but
like i was yesterday [ __ ] cleaning
the house
and i [ __ ] hate cleaning the house i
don't think
anyone in their entire life lies
cleaning the house and i didn't realize
why
my parents [ __ ] basically just every
parent manipulates their kids to be like
their personal slavery
when it comes to like cleaning the house
well that's that's the reason why they
used to have so many kids right it was
like they got to plow the fields yeah
right i intend to keep that british
philosophy alive when i have a kid
70 kids he needs to plow the fields and
clean the house
and prepare them connor's going to like
min max that [ __ ]
my house has uh six rooms so that's six
children i need to have at least
one per room i'm not i'm not gonna beat
my kids by the way that was a
distasteful joke just saying that now
yeah cause like why is the why is the
like activity of cleaning just
so awful like like
does anyone who is who actually enjoys
cleaning the house
when you do it when you have it like you
get rid of a lot of dirt
right that's why i let it build up i let
it get like gross right because when you
clean that [ __ ] it's like
peeling off a good scab all right oh oh
it's so clean
yeah but i need to see like a physical
layer of dust yeah in order for me to be
like yeah
when you swipe a whole layer of dust off
with like a wet wipe or something
damn that feels good that takes that i
get like a quarter job at least
but i don't like cleaning this no no
because like yeah that is a satisfying
feeling but my problem is that cleaning
just [ __ ] like
i never knew as a kid how much [ __ ]
time and effort it takes to clean
like like because okay when you're a kid
you just clean your own [ __ ] room you
move the lip
liner i didn't even do that or whatever
oh you you lucky [ __ ]
you like would i would but then five
minutes later be back to where i was so
my parents were just like whatever like
i still have [ __ ] vietnam flashbacks
of my mom calling me like
i know she's about to ask you to hoover
the living room i know it
i [ __ ] i don't want to come down
right now this time man having vietnam
but yeah like like i realized as an
adult the act of cleaning just like it
takes you all day
yeah and like the reason i hate it is
because it feels like you
you know when you do something
productive like you do you do like a
hard day of work or something
or like even playing a video game you
feel like you're making progress with
your life i don't know about the video
game thing but
i like like you know when like for me
whenever playing like a
first person game like a single-player
game right making progress with the
story yeah okay okay yeah
something
like the whole the entire concept of
cleaning is that
you're working towards making things
zero again you're working towards zero
yeah
you're walking you're working towards
making things normal again
oh what happened oh it switched off
sorry uh
joey joey uh laptop is [ __ ] but yeah
you're working towards
towards making the default state state
zero again right
and i'm just like this doesn't feel good
yet it takes so much time and energy to
do it yeah and no one prepared for
no one prepared this for me it's like
shoveling snow in a blizzard
yeah it's like it's gonna it's gonna
form back up again so it's like what's
the point i mean i only used to clean
i'm like
like this is how i would i would decide
if i'm gonna clean this day is somebody
coming to my house
no i'm not cleaning is somebody coming
that is still my stage yeah is somebody
coming to my house
fine i'll clean yeah you know the best
adult purchase i ever made was in the uk
it was a good vacuum i was like you know
what what's all this hype around those
dice and things right
what is all that because i i lived with
a friend yeah i lived with a guy and his
dad worked for the
henry henry hoover's yeah that was like
[Applause]
yeah yeah i don't know if these are in
america but they're they're everywhere
in the uk
right these things are like tanks they
don't die but they also kind of suck
yeah they don't suck good they should be
sucking good yeah and i'm like [ __ ] this
guy in my house
i was like i want to get a dyson he was
like no no no no no all you need is this
thing and he's like [ __ ] slap so he's
like it's a [ __ ]
unit this thing is and i i broke it
within like two weeks
uh yeah i mean that's my own fault [ __ ]
up
well that'll do it i was like oh no i
have to get a new one oh no there's a
puddle
quick grab the hoover oh no i have to
get a new a new vacuum [ __ ]
there so i bought a dyson dude that [ __ ]
like cleaned up like it could have oh my
god a carpet was a different color
i was like what have i been doing my
whole yeah yeah yeah no i i never
believed in that dyson [ __ ] too until i
bought one like a couple of years ago i
was like changes
let's see how good these are and i do i
was like all right
not buying anything else anymore this is
the one [ __ ] up to like max suck
oh my god it gives the good socks the
[ __ ]
the backside okay here's how i can okay
you know this dyson has all this
[ __ ] about rotating [ __ ] things
like 10 cylinders it's a lot of [ __ ] let
me tell you
why it's good right you know that one
piece that always sticks the [ __ ]
carpet that doesn't come off
dyson never has an issue getting that
one crumb out of the car yeah
that [ __ ] always comes out because the
normal vacuums they don't get that [ __ ]
out like
there's always that one [ __ ] thing
that for some reason won't come out you
gotta [ __ ] it it's just like clinging
onto the carpet yeah
and then you're like how many how many
rollovers am i gonna do this thing until
i just admit defeat bend over pull it
out of the carpet like an animal and
feed it into the vacuum like it's some
budget dog i'm like here you go here we
go
i don't like doing that yeah i don't
want to do that i'm not a peasant i
shouldn't have to touch my carpet
with my hands that's disgusting okay so
yeah that's how i can sell it to you you
will never have to bend over
you'll never have to bend you'll never
have to bend to the knee
yeah dude it's amazing dude and i that
was like my gift to my parents when i
went to japan because
i couldn't bring it with me right so i
was like parents you can have my prized
possession here is the vacuum
he's like i'm like i'm like bending over
like giving him like the sword of
camelot like [ __ ] here you go
take it take my dyson v12 max suck
edition
like she'd be fair she thought it was
all nonsense but she tried it she was
like all right connor this is a pretty
[ __ ] good kiss
you're
yeah